[Musique]
les brodeurs outils vous passer et
comment êtes vous arrivé ici
au départ nos parents nous ont envoyé à
la plage de ma la mer en tramway
principal j'ai eu une mauvaise nouvelle
à vous annoncer des enfants votre maison
est détruite et vous êtes orphelins à
présent on allait vivre chez le comte
ory là je dis tant que josé pinot sens
s'il a comploté avec est semée d
utiliser carmelita spat il kidnappe et
les triplés beaux draps la tuer jacques
snicket au village des fraudes yves
hinse tu ne peux pas le prouver
les baudelaire j'ai besoin de votre aide
c'est la mission la plus importante de
toute l'histoire des vf t
n'hésitons pas aller baudelaire tu nous
a déçu alors la fortune baudelaire c'est
des chiffres non je pense que c'est des
billets votre sumarah être
j'allais en tirait les vfd bonne fois
pour toutes viens voir papa
on peut y arriver pour jeudi aux
derniers havres sur l'autel des nounous
vous êtes volontaire
oui avec plaisir
c'est total et pourrait de visages
familiers
nos ennemis sont de plus en plus
hardiment sera toussaint
je vais prendre ma revanche sur tout le
monde a pris quoi qu'est ce qui sera
devenu emblème les apparences sont
parfois trompeuses les vaudois
nos parents nous former à la vf des sans
qu'on s'en rende compte
on peut pas le cuir est permanent
vous n'avez aucune question brûlante à
poser
des mystères non résolus
vous ne voulez pas savoir ce qui arrive
ensuite qu'arrive-t-il ensuite
violette klaus et prunille baudelaire je
m'appelle les manistes l'iccat
c'est bien du sang
[Musique]
non